ce sont nos députés et aux sénateurs qui
doivent monter au créneau et qui peuvent
qui doivent nous défendre d'ancêtres
dans cette problématique parce que je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est un véritable
besoin d'avoir des semences paysannes
des semences qui sont uniques chaque
grain et unique des semences qui ne sont
pas traitées non plus qu'ils n'ont pas
de produits chimiques qui sont saines
pour les personnes qui les utilisent
mais aussi surtout qu'ils sont adaptés
en fête au milieu où elles ont progressé
de spécimens au players des pour pouvoir
faire de la semence qui sont encore
peut-être plus adapté productives ou
bien le moustique ce qui est cerné tirer
alors qu'on achète 10 seulement ce qu'on
attendait d'eux peut pas faire ça j'ai
toujours de racheter c'est pas forcément
adapté à notre c'est tout un travail de
sélection de génération en génération va
garder ses correspondants fait avec quoi
nous attendre aux antilles pour aider
marié qui puisse résister
sérieux
la sécheresse est aussi qu'ils soient
s'arrose
[Musique]
la cour internet qui est très prisé ans
en europe n'est en fait c'est entre de
s'acclimater sur les syndicats ça fait
la deuxième génération de voitures note
la con haïtien
[Musique]